you guys had any regrets this year
oh [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] question
just gonna drop that bombshell nowhere
no
me neither are you gonna have regrets
i'm trying to think i just i just that
question just came up from the top of my
head not going to the gym
no regards
i regret
not studying kanji
like that
as we found out on the trash taster
stream
the other day um but actually i actually
regret not putting more time into
japanese because my japanese studying
has been like very spotty this year i'd
be like super into it and then like
something would happen and then like i
would take a day off and then that would
just like stack one to like two days and
three days and then suddenly i'd find
like a month
had been taken off of learning japanese
and then like the first
like the first few weeks of me getting
back into japanese it's just like me
re-learning the [ __ ] that i already knew
before right it's kind of like the gym
in that day right where in that way
where you make your gains and then you
stop going and then when you go back to
the gym you gotta like regain the gains
you already had yeah it just feels like
really demotivating it's like trying to
push through
it sucks i really want to go to the gym
more
but i'm just lazy
yeah are you are you just lazy or is it
just because you have
got so much going on in your life now
that you just don't have the time
i mean if i really really really want to
go to the gym i could make time you know
what i mean like but it's it's not
something that i enjoy as much as other
stuff but i really do want to go more
yeah well some days after i've like
after i've been and you know you hurt
for the next day i'm like and then the
day after that i'm like i'm like not not
great feeling a hundred percent but it's
the only time that week i have time but
i'm like yeah ah [ __ ] yeah maybe i'll go
maybe i won't uh yeah yeah it's tough
it's tough it's really annoying i don't
know my schedule is a lot more
unflexible now so
i think i have times to go it's just a
lot difficult a lot more difficult to to
get it in in the way i wanted it to yeah
because i think because you just have so
much more [ __ ] going on right so like
even if you are at the gym it's like oh
[ __ ] you're just thinking of all the
stuff that you could be doing otherwise
yeah
it just feels better right i travel a
lot more for videos as well now so yeah
that takes yeah it feels it feels weird
that there was a point where the sea dog
channel was just you inside filming
videos right now yeah i know my video is
not outside i'm just like kind of
slacking man kind of slacking what's
going on
this is what i'm worried about because
i'm like [ __ ] all right so let's say i
want to go back to the uk at some point
what the [ __ ] am i going to do on my
channel everyone's going to be like why
is he outside like so what was that a
[ __ ] do in the uk
just try every pint in weatherstream
yeah yeah
it's not bad actually
i'd watch that try every meal deal at
tesco
[Applause]
yeah i'd basically be like shitty tom
scott at that point
this is this is a house where they they
get water through a well it's really old
and stuff that's like the uk we don't
have anything interesting
we only have like really old quirky
stuff in the uk we don't have anything
modern that's like [ __ ] insane
yeah i guess that's why everyone travels
outside now okay
interesting stuff right i legitimately
don't know what i would do with my main
channel content if i ever move back to
the uk don't worry i don't have time
plans to make it's not happening it's
not happening anytime soon yeah just
boys keep me hostage
i don't know what i don't know what i
would do i mean this check titled trash
tastes keeps me hostage
that's the thing that's weird having
like having a specific spot i need to be
in every week like a job and when we
have to take holidays now we have to
tell the boys and put in our holiday
time to be like hey i'm going to be away
for this week um so uh yeah i mean we
could just put in the hours ahead of
time right yeah we could just like not
have trash taste some weeks but then
also it's like why why not we can easily
just make it every week yeah yeah yeah
exactly and i i'm not a fan of like the
whole uh not uploading on holidays
because i'm like i only like some of my
audience celebrate said holidays so i i
don't feel like it's fair to just be
like oh [ __ ] you guys people who don't
celebrate the same holidays as me
i'm not giving you content i'm busy i
mean it's a valid excuse i think in some
ways when you're like you're busy but
you know i also like uploading and i i
like the trash taste uploads every every
every week no matter what it's like no
matter how uh i don't know what people
are doing it's like you can expect that
you're going to get a trash taste every
day it's kind of like comfort food
because i like that about channels i
watch that like no matter where i am
even because sometimes you know maybe
christmas i got some down time you know
for an hour or two i might watch a video
that's come out that i'm really excited
for you know exactly i like it i like it
but the thing about christmas right it's
that okay so you have you have
you have the beginning right you wake up
early
with the family you open presents and
everyone opens their presents everyone's
all merry and happy so what happens
between like 11 o'clock to 4 o'clock
food and alcohol
no food alcohol and check this [ __ ] out
no because
food comes on at four right so what
food comes out about you don't
for christmas lunch whatever you want
what whatever you envision food a dinner
to be dude i'm about to have like an
all-you-can-eat buffet for dinner you
bet you better know that i'm saving
space for that christmas dinner well no
i have that buffet at lunch and then
don't have dinner
i have both because during dinner time
i'm busy getting drunk no dinner dinner
time christmas dinner it's like it's
like one of the best meals we don't do
that in australia what do you do in
australia though in australia we wake up
we have we get the you know open up all
the presents or whatever yeah uh and
then you know by that time it's around
lunchtime yeah and then all the family
comes over you have like you know kind
of a late lunch maybe like two three
o'clock type of like big big lunch
finish at like 5 p.m and then that's
when you get shit-faced with your family
and by the time dinner time rolls around
you're not hungry because you're still
full from the massive lunch i think i
have lunch and dinner christmas day yeah
it's like a lunch industry yeah it's for
me it's like it's one big meal no it is
one big meal
for me
how can your stomach handle yeah it's
christmas baby
that christmas spirit man like i i think
large is my stomach by four times like
the reason we don't have a christmas
lunch or i've never heard of anyone
having a christmas lunch is because i'm
pretty sure during christmas dinner you
eat enough to like fill yourself up for
a [ __ ] week well sometimes like you
have friends who can't come to the
dinner or something so i'll go i might
go meet them for lunch or something
going out on christmas day yeah i'll go
nowhere blasphemy i'll like go to their
house
what you don't spend with your family no
i'll spend the dinner with my family
because maybe there's someone who i
don't spend all day with your family no
no
not all the time sometimes i do it
depends on like who i can see when and
when i can't you know some people they
have like they're having a christmas
thing and i'll go and say hi i'll turn
up and then i'll go back and spend the
evening okay so like last time i went
back to australia i did that like i i
spent like a christmas dinner with my my
friend at my friend's place like my uni
mate but i did that the day after the
actual christmas event as like a late
christmas kind of thing right right
right but like on christmas day if i'm
not at home with my family no then
something's wrong if i'm if i'm not at
home
with the family or we're not going to
another one of our family's relatives
places yeah then then there's some beef
it's going on yeah some of them are
friends some of them are family you know
it's kind of a mix you know who it is
okay but like my justification for the
christmas lunch in australia is that you
have to understand that christmas day is
a very nice summer day
right so
going outside eating a massive thing by
a pool side is very normal in australia
yeah pass me the turkey i'm in the pool
right now yeah yeah exactly so i don't
have a roast no we do okay but outside
it gets cooked with the sun because it's
so hot yeah yeah yeah we we pop off we
just have a [ __ ] barbecue baby
not even we just go out onto the road
and just pop a whole chicken on the
tarmac and then it just cooks by itself
no but like it's it's like a usually
like you know
like 34 35 degree like nice summer day
right and it's like you're out on the
balcony with your family and you're
having a you know a nice roast or you
know pork or whatever it is that you eat
yeah you know during christmas and we
have that during the day because the
sun's out and it feels good you know
that's that that's my justification of
why we have one meal at like two o'clock
obviously if it was like that's so alien
to me yeah obviously it feels like
winter time right yeah i'm not gonna go
out
okay i'm
so as as someone who obviously grew up
in australia celebrating christmas that
way yeah do you do you have like this
christmasy feeling like what what do you
have a christmassy feeling or do you
have anything that gives you a
christmassy feeling yeah christmasy
feeling is when i'm having a beer at
like 2 p.m in a pool
that could be that's like any day for
australians joey
yeah christmas
hell yeah
is it like weird watching christmas
movies like we don't watch christmas
movies at all i don't at least our
family doesn't i mean
did you have like a christmas spirit
like uh like
like they got like dead inside no no no
no no why are you
because i remember because uh when when
i lived in thailand uh me and sydney
celebrated christmas there for like two
two or so years yeah and every every
year she'd she tell me you know what you
know the trees up you got we got the
christmas we got their christmas songs
on the roast is out but it just doesn't
feel like christmas she says as it is
like 35 degrees and like yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're outside no just doesn't turn
off
it doesn't feel like it
it just just doesn't feel like christmas
i mean you know we put up a tree and
everything and yeah we decorated it and
put the lights on it and stuff like that
but it's also you know i'm in my board
shorts and t-shirt at the same time
that just that just doesn't sound
festive to me it's like it's like board
short board shorts t-shirt christmas hat
you know
there's a yeah there's a great photo of
me like just with exactly that get up
standing in front of the christmas tree
sweating my nuts off because it was like
38 degrees okay okay okay so like
is there like a certain period of time
where you see something
you know and you're like oh christmas is
coming up you know because for me right
like in england you know it's it was
whenever
the weather would start getting like
really cold and then you'd start seeing
you know christmas decorations pop up
here and there what is it like in
australia
it's the same thing is it the same you
see christmas decorations pop up but at
the same time it's like oh i gotta start
taking this jacket off oh my god that's
so bizarre
that's how we do it
do you get any houses which like go
absolutely [ __ ] mental oh yeah
christmas decorations yeah absolutely
absolutely absolutely
but the problem is right but the problem
is because it's the summer time right he
can't turn the lights on until it's like
9 00 p.m
because it's still bright outside sorry
for [ __ ] santa claus and like with
like a like a hot red jacket oh he ain't
in a hot red jacket he has no shirt on
dude
he's in he's in red board shorts usually
no shirt honestly do you have like like
snowman decoration and [ __ ] like that oh
no i know
actually
snow in australia uh in some parts it
does yes so in canberra it does
um but not not where i'm from no not at
all it doesn't get cold enough it's like
the coldest it'll get maybe like 10
degrees oh yeah yeah but again like that
happens in july for us not uh not not
christmas still strange